hi slugs it's esther i miss you today
but make sure you check us out on andrew
schultz's show flagrant too me and
kelila had the best time over there i'm
going to be on the road march 18th i'm
coming to indianapolis then i'm headed
to philadelphia san diego austin texas
brooklyn new york washington dc and
chicago and more get tickets at
esteronice.com i can't wait
sluggies i am on the road i am out there
i'm hustling i'm telling jokes i'm
slinging jokes for you guys i'm so
excited
to meet you and perform for you it's
been such an honor
um you can see me i'm gonna be at the
berea improv one night only on march 3rd
please come out i'm gonna have surprise
guests with me it's gonna be such a good
time
i'll be in richmond virginia march 10th
through 12th las vegas
nevada march 18-19 san francisco april
15-16 syracuse new york
florida burbank flappers austin texas
tempe arizona so many more dates please
go to annieletterman.com
shows i can't wait to meet you
[Music]
i change
i have such a good akash story i'm so
excited i wonder if you know what it is
i don't oh it's so good akash i i've
told it i told it to like a random
guy at a club recently where i was like
he brought you up and i was like i got
an akash store he waited the whole meet
and greet and then i was like here it is
all right i'm excited okay are we
recording and everything okay yeah
so
you were working at the village lantern
yeah yeah yeah and you had been like
hustling barking barking for anyone that
doesn't know it's like when you go out
you
you're like promoting the show pretty
much you're like on the street like
begging people to come into a basement a
dark basement it was a dark basement in
the lower east side right yeah yeah
village village yeah yeah yeah so it's
good it's like it was it was a good spot
and it was like an angle to get into
comedy that i had not i had gone through
like the mics and stuff you guys like
were hustling and getting real shows
pretty much like bringing the audience
in right so i just come in you've just
been working there for however long yeah
i just roll in someone gave me a spot
okay i roll in all cocky i have no clue
how this works or anything i don't know
what i'm i'm hosting okay
and they're like they're like all right
you're gonna bring up next you're gonna
bring up akash sing and i go oh gosh
thing okay akash singh akash singh akash
thing i'm like all right i'm gonna
memorize this i got it i got it i get on
stage someone heckles something and it
sends me into a story about [ __ ] yeah
and the word [ __ ] and the word akash
held the same space in my brain and it
knocked akash out and so then this man
who has been busting his ass to do this
forever okay you like probably brought
the audience in that i was performing in
front of
i go i have to go okay the next comedian
coming to the stage is
mr singh and you were like
20 probably yeah no no i had to call you
i had to but i mean i was your age so
you were you were not that old you were
a child to be being called mr singh
i just i think about that
you know it's funny i don't even
remember that i'm so glad you don't
because i would hate me if i were you no
i'll tell you a story i remember that i
resent you for uh
i you should do my show a lot i would
let you do shows and i would never care
how comedians did i was like yo i'm
process oriented for everybody but me i
was super hard on myself and then you
would go and every time you come
upstairs and be like god damn that was
rough and i was like that's fine come
back whatever and then i asked i was
like yo you got a hot show can i do it
and you were like
ah i don't know we're kind of booked up
and i was like does this [ __ ] just bomb
on my show
what time was it also my show did get
300 people in it though
at a time yeah yeah no she had paid and
stuff it was like a yeah
i definitely did have i was the always
the worst comic on my own show no no no
it wasn't it wasn't it was i was looking
at you like you were my level i was
going like you know there's only one one
that's what was killing me i was like
you just told me you bombed and i'm like
you're sorry can you barbie bomb in
front of that many people i don't know
there's so few people in that basement i
i had for years i was like this [ __ ]
i would listen i would have you on now
oh thanks
let's go back to 300 percent can you get
me andrew's contact no i'm talking no i
honestly i did have i was like a nazi
about my booking and stuff yeah again it
just bothered me because you had just
bombed no i jeremiah i did the same
thing to him where i like talk [ __ ] on
his show not rosing it was his show like
i was just like i think i'd like it's a
testament to how truly i had bombed
because you're kind of you know you're
not like in your body right right oh i'd
be having those bumps and then you're
like i'm just spewing shut up that's
i could have used uh
i could have used you on that lineup
yeah i'm thinking about it like you
would have been i don't know exactly if
i would have i wasn't i'm not gonna find
like i was some killer back then but i
was like i know i get the job done that
much i know i'm i think i'm pretty good
like i could do better than you did on
my show that yes yeah for sure for sure
but also i had to like there were people
that were actually really good too not
that i'm saying you weren't no no you're
free that were like like pro level that
i couldn't have on because it was like
the acoustics of the place and stuff too
but i
understand i hear you i'm glad it got
out of the way you know tell all stories
well
i'm glad that was a great warm-up have
cost i have to have called you mr singh
and i'm like sorry
i thought you were just gonna go with
bukhaki maybe [ __ ] is a fun word to
say i understand that i i would go on a
rant two of ozuba bukkaki as a word i
was sweating i just remember being like
oh my god like just really like there's
no way out i had no option i don't my
name gets [ __ ] up so like no black
host has ever gotten my name right
dude akisha koosh whatever
i got called amash i used to do all hood
rooms so for the longest times guy
called me amash
i would do great on his shows and then
when i finally corrected him i started
bombing non-stop it was really
unfortunate you got two you like became
a person yeah yeah yeah yeah do you do
you correct people all the time i let
things just go sometimes i don't care
how non-indians pronounce my name if
you're indian and you mispronounce it
like you say akash it's like you know
better it's like
or akash there's like a strong k with it
yeah but it hangs on the a right so it's
akash well some people say oh gosh my
in-laws say akash so maybe that's like
where they're from how it's said but i
honestly i say akash i hear people say
oh gosh i don't mind however anybody
else says it i don't care yeah you don't
dictate my identity yeah but when an
indian has like akash with that soft
soft i'm like you know better don't do
that
i think you said akash when i walked and
i didn't notice i truly don't know yeah
i don't care yeah but kalila i want to
make that right yeah but but it's kind
of like a westernized version of
hallelujah so it's even a harder oh i
think we should start pronouncing it
that i mean yeah because my my father
spoke like his family even though they
were french they lived in egypt and so
he's uh he he spoke arabic fluently yeah
yeah yeah so it's it's a play on
what does it mean
it's like divine friend or divine
something something fire but yeah but
it's like khalil like khalil gibran yeah
it's just a girl version of that
yeah but imagine my whole i don't
correct people yeah if even if if i'm in
starbucks somebody says my name whatever
you want it to be yeah and i think that
i'm doing it wrong i think that i'm not
honoring what my dad wanted me to be
named i'm torn on this because people
pronounce my last name wrong and it's i
never care because unless someone the
worst is when someone brings you up and
they're like this is my best friend my
favorite comedian and then they just
butchered what do they say
leaderman or like i've been called amy i
mean and i don't like my ego doesn't get
involved i don't care but then but then
i'm thinking about it and there's
lara bites is lord if you call her laura
she will get really mad at you and i
remember being like so what [ __ ] but
then i was like some whites no but then
i was like
respect for yourself okay yeah i think
so like can you say my [ __ ] name
right i think i'm spineless i think no i
think it's only important how you say it
because you dictate your identity you
don't let other people dictate so if you
say it how you want to say it that's all
that matters i say akash and that's all
that matters how do we care about
spellings now with kalila when we became
friends you were k for so long
but then i got it down i got it done
here's what i'll say about
i have a family in germany and every
time they always say it's lederman tell
her it's litaman i'm gonna tell her i
thought they were gonna say are they
gonna say they spelled your name kkk i
was like wow i am i mean my initials are
kkk i'm missing something now okay
have you done your 23 and me and all
that i haven't i have yeah no that's no
you know what do i need you know yeah i
know there's a surprise there's
something white in there because i got
green eyes for sure but like i'm not
concerned about what kind of white this
beautiful green eye i want to apologize
to akash wife's for i did have a moment
where i gazed deeply into his eyes
it's because he kind of called it out
though okay now wait you you got married
what three years ago no i got married
six months ago we got engaged before the
pandemic we're supposed to get married
october 2020. pandemic [ __ ] that
obviously so we moved it then moved it
again then moved it back was that like
hell july it must have been the worst it
was rough did you ever consider just
like eloping you can't is that anything
it's too much family we try to do it in
india but then india got delta and that
[ __ ] everything up so we ended up just
doing it she's very good at like her gut
is always right and i was like push to
october and then she said nas do it july
did you go with the full big
there's no way it's not doing full india
and i didn't want it just because the
money and the planning and the stress
but it ends up being so worth it dude
the wedding is the best traditionally
who's supposed to pay for it in indian
wedding traditionally the bride's family
i think yeah and that's part of i guess
like and then there's dowry and all this
other [ __ ] but with us it was like our
parents don't have a ton of money so we
take care of it the last time the last
time i was in new york was right before
the pandemic it was for an indian
wedding yeah but um it was my friend
she's vietnamese married um my other
friend who's an indian guy yeah and um
there's a lot of family drama when um
from indian mothers west side story yeah
dude you're
your friend hates your indian friend's
mom for sure and vice versa if mom hates
her yeah
well first she's not indian that's a
problem yeah but it's pretty close so
the whole wedding i was there for like a
week and a half i was just indifferent
like i was in vietnamese garb and then i
was in this yeah but it was so fun i was
like
do you guys remember camp nowhere i
think i brought it up maybe 10 million
times on this show because it was my
favorite movie growing up you're my same
age okay so it was it's uh christopher
lloyd who was in back to the future
plays this creepy little oh wait my wife
might like love this movie i think she
does yeah
before christopher lloyd she loves it
yeah yeah he's just like nobody really
addresses that he's this creepy man
that's like around children somehow yeah
but he hooks up with these kids that all
of their parents want them to go to
these traditional camps yes science camp
whatever and then so he
he becomes like the fake camp counselor
so then all of the kids are in on it so
they'll have like a parent's weekend
where they all pretend they're at fat
camp which i don't know how they pulled
that one off or pretend that they're you
know at whatever camp so we should do
one for for weddings for
traditionally religious weddings where
we pretend for each family
that the wedding you know you throw like
a fake one like this is the wedding so
good and then don't invite those
oh yeah i guess you might as well have
this [ __ ] yeah i don't know how they i
don't know
the cost of your indian slash vietnamese
wedding is probably crazy i paid six
figures i mean her parents have my
parents help were they but let's be real
they cooked their own food probably
right no no no it was crazy because i
was many people i honestly jumped from
like a cafe you've been to work
oh yeah
we do there was a flan the size of this
room yeah it was a big flood we don't
[ __ ] around with food okay yeah
filipinos that's like that's our only
like olympic sport that we get right
yeah it's food food food and it's always
like are you hungry no no thanks okay
eat some more yeah there's no saying no
it is so offensive to turn down food i
don't give a [ __ ] if you have to
shove that you know last piece of
chicken in the bathroom quite i don't
just don't say no bobby wants to fit in
really well with your family yeah he's a
fatty we love a fatty
we love a fatty
did you ever have to hide your food like
yeah i used to shove it and when i was
younger you were feeding it to the dog i
remember one time i think i must have
been eight years old where my mom was
just like what is that smell and i
remember just
like shoving meat onto the sofa because
i couldn't i don't know if you know this
akash but i was like heavily abused as a
as a child i couldn't i wasn't allowed
to hold my own utensils when i was until
i was about 13 years old i was spoon-fed
by my mother i was like her racehorse i
did not know about that that is the most
that's the craziness of all the things
i've heard yeah so i had a control issue
till i was about 12 or 13
and um i swam for the philippine
national team since i was like eight
years old so i was like just her
racehorse i swam i made money and she
spoon fed me but she overfed me so
oftentimes i would take the food out of
my mouth and i would shove it in corners
because i felt like vomiting and if i
vomited she would put another plate of
food say you have to i and she i could
not leave i could not go to school
anywhere until she shaved your body for
you too dude i've been a shaved
child since i was like four years old
did you ever on the swim team no this is
how not asian filipinos are your mom was
like no you're gonna make it in
athletics and every generation is like
be a doctor
anything else are you [ __ ] crazy no i
had to be both yeah yeah it was like
you're going to be a doctor and you're
also going to be an olympic swimmer and
i have business owners too is that asian
culture to like own stuff for us yeah
for us open your own business don't
matter if it does well that's such a
good
thing to teach your kids yeah oh my god
yeah but i would have there would be
rotten food all over the house and i
still remember the smell and my mom
would always wonder what is that [ __ ]
smell in this house
and i'm like you over feeding your child
and her hiding that food yeah that's
rough i know
does it make you want to have kids less
because yeah through all that [ __ ] yeah
that's the rough part i'm i'm so
trepidatious about whether or not i can
parent correctly because i think that my
sensors are all broken
does that make sense nah i can tell by
your energy you can be great yeah you
are maternal you're watching you kill my
own kid i'll blame both of you never you
know never i'm trying to impregnate my
wife every day bruh
i love kids dude i know the most
i think that i feel the same way i love
children i love babies yeah you're
always surrounded by babies that like i
like mama too yeah and i love that
feeling i just i'm so afraid of mine we
are talking about esther if anyone was
wondering
i mean i don't know if you've seen what
esther's up to but she's trying to
suckle those teeth
every day i don't know how much you know
i have been a mother a lesbian mother
tester for yeah i've been trying to
impregnate her
i did not know that but i don't blame
her you're maternal that's a good thing
my rehearsal this is how [ __ ] gay i'm
about kids my wife said to me this
weekend i'm excited about having a baby
i swear to god i teared up i was like oh
let's go let's go i have a question for
you is
is sex still just as as fun as and
exciting when you're actively trying for
a baby we haven't started actively
trying it because we're like she's
got she wants she's in school and all
that and she wasn't that warm on the
idea of having kids initially she was
like yeah i guess you know i want to
have kids but like i'm not super excited
about it and we had planned to start
trying probably within this year so we
wanted to wait till after we were
married obviously give it a year you'd
explore your career do whatever and
she's younger than me i'm 37 she's 28 so
we got a little time
but now when she's like when she's gonna
be like yo let's start trying i don't
know if it'll get old but i feel like
every day i'm gonna be so [ __ ] hype
that's good your kid's gonna come out
positive like haunted and like loved
um do you think that's a big age gap
between you and your wife it was early
on but
so we were each other's first
like i i was trying not to have sex when
i got married and then i remember when i
was third oh that's what you call it
trying
yeah yeah i saw how you dressed
[Laughter]
you also saw no you're just cute
and i was on tv for a couple of years
and i was like this you know this is i'm
really not getting anything out of this
what was your fault was that guy code
was the first thing the while and i was
like
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah you did do guy
code eventually though right yeah and
like it was all the guy yeah there's a
bunch of 16 year olds telling me i was
cute and i was like this is weird isn't
it weird
because we weren't that old but we were
like that was some some girl sent me her
screenshot of her wallpaper and it was
me and i was like what the [ __ ] is
happening
but i remember when i hit 30 i was like
look i'm not married so i'm not waiting
till i'm married but it's got to be
somebody that i feel like is special and
then i met my wife pretty quickly we
were like now this is even though
she was 22 i was 31 it was like i was so
immature in relationships it kind of
you're the exact age my parents were
when they they actually got married when
my mom was 22 my dad was 31. really no
we couldn't get married then neither one
of us was ready but we made it through
all the [ __ ] i think bobby's way too
young for me he has not hit like a
maturity her dad would be 100. oh let me
you that's not a bad age gap you and
your wife my dad was 36 years older than
my mom up dog that [ __ ] got game
i respect this guy how wait how old was
she she wasn't a weird age was she she
was a weirdish age uh 21. oh he was 57.
she must have been so hard he was an
expat but my dad he wasn't a sloppy 50
something year old like he was a success
fan
rich he was like very lived a very
affluent life comes from old money um
and he looked good he looked like
richard gere yeah he earned a 21 year
old are you yeah
are you
in touch with his side of the family at
all the old money they're very snooty
very wealthy white artists from
switzerland wow and they all live there
um we kind of email here and there but
like the extent of that relationship is
really kind of cocky on their end it's
like oh yeah go visit my gallery in la
at this gal and i'm like
no man i wanted to we're first we're
first cousins yeah like did you watch
our show we talk about gyms
um listen guys things get rough and i
admittedly have a lot of issues that
i've dealt with since i was very young i
have
very long bouts of depression i have
extreme anxiety which is why
of all the things in my life that i find
completely indispensable it is therapy
without therapy i don't think i would be
alive to see this day
wow this is a dark one but guys it's
true these subjects listen we're
podcasters our lives couldn't really get
better and we still need better help do
you know what i mean there's no shame in
needing therapy and
you know all of the excuses you used to
have you don't want to drive you don't
want to find parking you don't want to
find it's hard to find the right doctor
you don't want to wait in the waiting
room all of those things are taken care
of now with better help and also it's
like even if you are the most balanced
even killed person on the planet daily
life stressors are eventually going to
add up and get to you which is
all the more reason to have
something to sound off to a therapist
just have fun sometimes you're just
bored you want to chat with someone
whose job it is to listen to you the
great thing about better health too is
that you can start communicating with a
therapist in in um just under 48 hours
yeah you can try out a bunch of
different ones too it's you know that's
the key i love that it's like sometimes
it's not a match and the fact that you
can just without any guilt be like you
know what this didn't work out i'm gonna
go see another therapist
that's also an option another option you
can journal yeah if you if if
you know there's still five days before
your next therapy appointment and you
have big feelings write them down
there's a journal feature it's great
save your loved ones and get better help
we want you to start living a happier
life today as a listener you'll get 10
off your first month by visiting our
sponsor at betterhelp.com
trash tuesday join over 1 million people
who have taken charge of their mental
health again that's betterhelp
h-e-l-p-dot-com
trash tuesday check out betterhelp.com
trash tuesday
here's what would excite me if i walked
into a man's room if i saw that he had
manscaped products yeah because then i
know he has balls are deodorized yeah
his bush is trimmed
and he's generally taking better care of
himself and you don't have to wait till
you go into the bathroom and see the
hair stuck to the toilet seat
you know right away
he's
his lower area is cleaner than even his
toilet and the likelihood of him having
nicks on his balls or shaft very low yes
listen this is manscaped they're not
messing around and they're they're not
just having
the trimming of the pubes now they have
body washes now todd and i shower
together because we like to connect
they're real lovers we shower together
and
we you know we squish up we we lather up
and we squish on each other and it's
really nice manscaped is
we're pretty much having a threesome
with manscaped is what i'm saying and
their body wash is infused with aloe
vera and sea salt shower gel sounds like
a he smells like a man he smells like a
man smells like a man they also have a
two in one shampoo and conditioner it's
a nourishing and luxurious two in one
far above the rest infuse also with sea
kelp and coconut water sounds like
kaleila to me and not to mention this is
all on top of their already amazing
lawnmower 4.0 you guys if you're not
um
we don't mind hair we don't mind hair
just you know occasionally show us that
you care
trim okay use manscape to trim this hair
and then use the manscape shampoo
to get this hair smelling good all right
wash your armpit hair with their body
wash they're covering all your hairs
okay your hairs are taken care of get 20
off plus free shipping with a code trash
at manscape.com that's 20 off plus free
shipping with a code trash at
manscape.com the only smell you'll want
on him in a bottle thanks to manscape
[Music]
old money doesn't care about new money
they don't they don't care that that's
why i don't press old money because it's
their identity is that they they just
have things yeah like think about like
how i've gone like since i started
making money i mean i am like
i'm buying glasses i'm losing them i'm
buying it again i'm like i'm a spender
yeah and i'm like i'm starting to feel
like i deserve it if i was born feeling
like that was just my life it would be i
would never talk to her like get away
from me peasant no they probably look at
that like uh
like because i remember as a comic julio
galarati is like friends of these super
rich people and i just went over to
their house once for like yeah
he is i was in his house in like this
crazy apartment in new york city and i
remember the the guy that was his friend
had in new york city his own massive
bedroom bigger than any bedroom i've
seen with a walk-in closet in a bedroom
and like a six bedroom apartment and
then like 15 different cologne bottles
and i was like oh money doesn't mean
anything to this guy truly it has no
meaning it's just a thing i whatever but
i want something i just get it yeah so
they probably look at people who think
that [ __ ] is cool like oh come on you
just buy it
that's how my dad lived for a long time
until he lost it all but even when he
lost it all he
would not pay for onions or garlic
because he think he his idea was he was
above paying for bulbs like he would go
to the grocery store and just grab
things and just walk out it was dark
that is fire honestly i'm like you're
poor [ __ ] is what they had to
use to light the room because
that's hilarious
that's hilarious i love that kind of
[ __ ] though dude white dudes don't get
enough credit for that kind of [ __ ] i
know it's like you they just don't pay
for bulbs that's fire dude we talk about
white male privilege now [ __ ] that
[ __ ] and where are
like flavor to your food well no i'm
saying like yeah he's oh he would go
pick it or whatever no he would steal it
from the grocery store
can i tell you the
people that i know who shoplift are
usually the richest people yes
because they they're shoplifting for
other reasons like your dad like it was
like a thrill
it's just privilege yeah how dare you
tell me i need to pay for this garlic
from gilroy you gotta respect that on
some level right yeah yeah when he first
moved to the philippines he lived in the
hotel for two years
and when we our family car was a taxi
cab he bought a taxi cab ah
so he could look like he was being
driven yes
he was an [ __ ] yeah that's sad that's
sad
i was like but the stealing is cool as
[ __ ] that's so cool do you have a car
you don't have a car no no we do have a
car yeah we're in 2011 honda where does
it go it's in a garage
do you use it yeah my wife goes to
philly like she's from philly oh really
so where is she from she is her family
lived i forget where she moved to the
suburbs when she was younger but she's
from maybe northeast or something okay
uh bucks bucks county okay i'm from
montgomery county okay i was like oh my
god oh wait she's young maybe i babysat
her yeah
most of those those kids didn't make it
no indeed don't do babysitters we have
family yeah we have moms oh filipinos
don't either yeah but she didn't want to
come to the city and i wanted to be in
the cities i was like look i'll try to
make it as easy for you to get out of
the city as we can so we're like by the
west side highway so she can go to uh
jersey quickly and got a car so just
army fairly quickly so yeah we just
honda civics are evergreen they'll never
go out of style i'm about to get rid of
mine they sent a cord but it's no i'm
getting it
i love the hatchbacks from like was it
like the early that was my first car was
it 2000 no no no no 2000 1993 honda
civic well you were a hot boy you were a
cool guy yeah i can't do it i was i was
i was supposed to be but i didn't like
soup it up or whatever you got honda i
was toyota i was camera i had a 1993
camry for you my dad was honda so we
were honda but toyota fire too i'll get
a toilet yeah it's the same thing my
rental car now is a toyota to see any
toyota sienna van i was like i want a
minivan minivan i like that
do you like tuck in like a baseball or
like a a couple of soccer balls into uh
no i might i might put a watermelon in a
babysitter
you know i mean visualization type [ __ ]
um i think that you're right toyota
siennas are underrated and i think more
single people should have our santa oh
siennas are the they're they're
the fans they are they're smooth drive
so comfortable minivans are pretty good
the greatest car on earth is a minivan i
think so it's a it's a bentley for a
family yeah i agree i mean like what do
you suv dude i got friends that have
kids and like i'm not getting a minute i
have an suv their life sucks the kids
are always uncomfortable if you ought to
sit you got to squeeze in between them
like a [ __ ] idiot it's terrible get a
minivan wait did you guys ever have a
minivan when you were little that was
like the one do you remember when they
used to have the ones i don't know if
they were the minivans but it was some
hatchbacks but you would face
towards the back yes
do you remember how [ __ ] fun that was
to like sit in the back i think it ended
up being like probably beheading a
couple children
something happened where it no longer
happens at all ever so it's swivel the
chair would swivel and you don't even
look at my cam down to look at me
they're just [ __ ] around in the back
you're like higher you'd have like a
was pickups not being used as pickups in
america like when i first came here i'm
like why aren't there eight people in
the back why aren't there all the people
in wheelchairs being driven around
exactly
yeah no i was always insistent on
sitting in the back and then they
started to realize how easily you could
die
just get launched off and then i
realized i was like oh people drive a
hundred miles an hour because that's so
fun yeah too much it's not enough
traffic you go fast you want to now are
convertibles still a thing is that still
like todd will be like i want to convert
one like i feel like that's for girls i
don't know i remember when we got a
convertible in hawaii yeah and like my
lashes fell off like you were so funny
todd okay so we went to hawaii and there
was like two nice days my boyfriend came
with us
and he rented this like convertible uh
land rover range river yeah and um
isla was in the back it was starting to
turn the weather was it was like the
last moment where it was like starting
to trickle because i was like in the
back like
well it's never fun in the back of a
convertible it only works for the people
in the front seat and then the guy that
was with us was trying to talk to you
and he's like screaming he's like i just
want to let you know tiger belly meant a
lot to me
i just have to have this one moment
where i want to tell you you really got
me through the pandemic she's like
her eyelashes up here
[Laughter]
oh [ __ ] i was like todd do not put the
top up don't you [ __ ] dare
drizzle a little oh god oh you're good
it's sparkling you're good oh my god i'm
scared
good you're gonna be a good dad yeah i'm
telling you the shame of dropping that
was immediately taken from me thank you
it's all good dude you know what i mean
um
yeah god annie thank you i don't respect
a man in a convertible a man who drives
a convertible i don't respect you i
don't know why it's just soft
i would love your boyfriend owns a
convertible no no he wants to and i'm
down for you
i'm down for you dude i'm gonna get you
guys you have about them i'm gonna get
you guys a honda odyssey you can be
living your best life you would actually
love that i think and odyssey is a great
car here's what i was thinking this is
why i was asking about cars so
at the comedy store
the big big time comics will come in in
like uh
they'll be driven in and giant like
suburbans or like
these giant big black suvs and i always
go like who's here and then sometimes
it'll be someone where i'm like
that person
and then i'm like but they live here
like it doesn't make any sense and
they'll be like oh i think they're
trying to like not get covered and i'm
like what yeah but i like the comedy
star parking lot flex yeah that is a
flick it's really really good i almost
want to tell you a thing i'm planning
but wait what's the flex with the type
of car they driving yes you drive in and
having a spot is a flex period like
pulling in already kind of a flex but
you can see some some people that get
past early on they come chugging in and
some
things are getting dragged i mean esther
just had her
upgraded her car finally there i started
here so i didn't now you did you did
that for like a year and a half oh were
you a teen comic no no i was 22. oh
that's because it's a while and out no
while now when i was like 28 29 but it
was like 22 i moved right out of college
here because i was like oh comedy l.a
show business i didn't know so i started
here but any time anybody pulled up
you're like oh that guy's passed and i'm
parking [ __ ] eight blocks away so
this guy's doing it to me well do you
want to hate me more yeah okay so i got
past first audition yeah and i didn't
know what it was didn't know what it was
had no clue i just came in with the same
cocky disgusting arrogance that would
just [ __ ] on your show too
like i just had no i was like
autistically just like doing comedy
right
so i just rolled in i had no clue what
the audition was i didn't know it was a
big deal at all it was like oh they have
names on the walls like no clue
got passed right away didn't understand
like what it was so i come pull in
and doc who's on
bad friends now he was the guy that
worked in the well you remember probably
from when you lived here yeah so he was
the only guy that parked back then
and he was like you can't park here you
have to park somewhere else and i was
like oh really tommy told me to come
park here and he was like nope and i
went i swear i was told to park here and
then i like he was like all right well
you can go in and talk to tommy but then
so i go and i come back out and he goes
oh you didn't tell me you were paid
regular
like why didn't i was like well i did
want this moment but it wasn't that
wasn't why i just like didn't know what
it was no i don't that's good for you
yeah don't i feel like it's an [ __ ]
would you like i'm a paid regular that
to me sounds more cocky so it's like
well do you know what i see every every
three months at the comedy store i'm
sure even when you've gone in kalei
you've seen something like this carlos
has definitely seen this there's always
a comic they'll get like a new door guy
that won't know who the paid writers are
there's always a paid regular screaming
at a new person do you know who i am and
you're like
this is so dark this is so embarrassing
because they do not know who you are
they definitely don't
yeah dude yeah yeah yeah i've seen lots
of screaming into the
into the i dated a couple of them
wait annie speaking of car talk
what's up with the tesla i have no
[ __ ] clue really yes i gave it back i
ordered i ordered it it's taking so long
i don't want it anymore yeah cancel the
order i was gonna get one too but they
didn't pass that eight thousand dollar
credit that's how indian i am like you
can't give me my money back i paid an
extra eight thousand for it that's how
quite new money i am
i was like tesla how much money do you
want i'll give it to you yeah i just
waited in a year or two you're gonna be
fine they're gonna up the mileage it's
gonna be great so long it's like the
longest i've ever waited for anything in
my life now cancel this one get the new
model 2023 would be great i know because
it will come out then
la's such a car city that makes me want
less of a nice car i'm a minivan guy
from now on if i move here you feel like
but do you feel like
you're cooler because you live in new
york and i i you can be honest because
i've been in both of those areas yes
yeah i look down on l.a yeah i got to
wear a mask still here
new york didn't to new york's credit and
i don't defend new york a lot but they
didn't want to do the mask mandate the
governor of the state passed it so we
had to but i remember when i went what
was annoying was just
you guys before we had to show our
vaccines you guys had to show your taxes
but now we have to do it everywhere i'm
fine again vaccinated if i want to wear
a mask i don't want you both i wanted i
betrayed my age i betrayed my asian
roots i really wanted uh toyota tacoma
because she said that asian tacoma those
are so cool too um because i i dive and
i have a lot of dive gear i want
something i could just throw in the back
of the truck yeah um but my step-dad and
everyone else were like no you you know
you're a grown-up now
and i [ __ ] i got an audi instead
although when i did drive the audi i was
like oh gosh
do you know how to make cars tacoma
would be awesome though
i think my next car will be uh attacking
two cars does rudy drive um she drives
bobby's beat up um prius which is the
family heirloom i i i finally accepted
the fact that that beat up
three
um what do you call it three door prius
that bobby drives is a family heirloom
yeah we can never get rid of that it's
gonna be passed down for generations i
think i think you could sell it like to
a museum
if there ever becomes a car yeah like
petrified wood you know what petrified
wood is
when you make when you approach me in
that car
i'm like i don't want to get whatever's
poisonous i had to buy my first car from
my dad
oh really i think i actually might even
propose that it is i think i want to be
i think i want to be indian that's the
kind of parent i think i'm going to be i
think i might have this is even worse i
think i might have been like yo let me
give you some money for this because i
don't want to just take a car that seems
very spoiled he's so responsible
yeah we had money for a little bit and i
felt guilty about it and then we lost it
and i was like why was i feeling so
guilty about this money man i just spent
that [ __ ] up you know i
if i could go back in time
you have a lot more i would love to give
you i would love to give you one of
those spots
that pays that pays and for the 300
people
oh i wish i could have it was a great
show i love how you do remember like the
the things that hurt you in the very
beginning like when you first start when
like you're a brand new comic because if
there's anything that bobby remembers
the most
his
[ __ ] list or his little hate box in his
heart it's just everybody from age 21 to
24. when you were still hateful and
angry right i remember like 27 i was
like dude i can't keep being like this i
don't like who the [ __ ] i am anymore
yeah for 10 years i worked on not being
so angry and being more positive and
[ __ ] like that i'm still not where i
want to be but those yeah yeah i still
hold on to a lot of them [ __ ] so because
when you do hold on to them you're like
am i mad i'm mad at uh what were you
like 23 at that point whatever
like if i were mad at you about well i'm
the one that did the wrong but
you know like i like i i was like
thinking about i was mad at this girl
from high school like i'm mad at a 16
year old girl yeah 100 like goodbye yeah
you you're released you can live your
life akash i have a question for you i
have a dilemma and it involves an
ex-boyfriend and annie knows all about
ex-boyfriends bobby should kill him
thank you this is what i think so i get
a i get a text you imagine bobby like
running at you like what
i'm about to get a hug do you know
that's what bobby does he thinks he's
the brawn of the house look at me i'm
five foot eight
i was a you know division one swimmer
for most of my life um he thinks he's
the braun of the house so when we hear
like noises around the house he pulls
out a fake katana that he got from set
it's not even a real bug
because he has to overcompensate he does
and he wields this thing he's like i'm
ready babe i got him
anyways
it's really sad but also kind of hot for
a fatty but yeah well he can't have a
gun let's be real baby he's gonna die
which at least buys you time to run i'll
gladly die for my girl no problem i
ain't probably gonna be able to do much
but i'll be a distraction
i just like that bobby's like coming
he's like you know what i'm good at
acting he's like i'm gonna play a role
he like gets into character yeah he
really has a good time when there's an
intruder yeah a possible intruder this
is like favorite time of year
but um i have a so a couple weeks ago i
get a text and it's from an x
and it says what was the perfume that
you used to wear
and i knew exactly what it was because i
still wear it so i'm like oh it's um you
know a sense of peace blah blah blah and
i'm like oh like do you have a new
girlfriend like congrat whatever i
didn't try to pry in too much he goes no
i'm buying it for myself
and
i at first i was like
okay maybe he's maybe he's gender fluid
fluid whatever that's fine and perfume
can be male whatever there's no assigned
gender to ascent
but then i'm like is he out to kill me
he wants to put up is he plotting here's
the thing
here's the thing you're like a
kardashian
okay i've been watching the big brother
celebrity big brother lamar odom's been
on it he's like chloe i love i'm not
gonna do black scent
um but he's like talking about chloe and
he misses her i mean that was what seven
years ago and they're the guys that go
nuts kanye's having the biggest mental
break something about the kardashians
keeps the it's like you get you
penetrated their soul like a kardashian
you are a k name
kk okay so he's not over it
no it's been a decade
that's weird that is right that's weird
and it didn't end well then
like he had someone follow me at the end
of that race now it's a problem he wants
you back he's not gonna hurt no no he
wants to no i think he wants me dead why
don't you say his name on the podcast so
everybody knows that something happens
do you think wait i actually think i
know what it is
i think i know what it is he wants the
perfume because when he skins you and
makes a pillow
he wants the skin to because the perfume
does isn't going to smell good right it
needs to be matched with your pheromones
yeah bond number nine sense of peace do
your pheromone stay on your skin after
you're skinned
no doctor singh
doctors no i don't think so i don't
think they would i think it's just going
to be the skin and that's going to rot
but
yo you should first of all say this
guy's name second of all i you should
have been blocked his number no you you
definitely should you definitely should
i don't really got no x's coming after
me so no i don't speak to mine yeah [ __ ]
them you're gone everyone's gone
you know what i mean everyone's the
hottest guy in comedy i do
esther esther
dipsy is an audio app it's so cool it's
an audio app full of short sexy stories
designed to turn you on as a new
squirter guys i do think i am the
authority on getting sexy and this will
help you reach your wettest peak here's
what i'll say about this i think we live
in a world that's so full
of like visual
pornography no knock to them
but we
i'd like to kind of move past that and
to really try and tap into the auditory
experience yes create your own take the
words of the author and use your
imagination and create
the hot throbbing member that is going
in and out of you each dipsy audio story
features characters that feel like real
people like me and annie and immersive
scenarios
like annie and todd in the shower i mean
you guys
so you feel like you're right there with
them
can we do a dip can we have our own
dipsy i'd like to pitch that um the
girls of trash tuesday read a dipsy
story or create one because i feel like
this is right up our alley this is we
should be like partners with these
people so you can listen to stories
about hooking up with your hometown
crush i love this this is like the
equivalent of dry humping dry humping is
the best thing ever guys just roll it
back there's too much of the obvious
explicit
visual stuff out there we should feast
our ears once bring us yes bring us back
to um
uh a time when we were too young for you
to bang us but now we aren't do you know
what i mean
it's like let's teeter on that line also
i've read erotica okay it's you're the
pages are sticking together by the end
it's too much concentration you need to
just lay back and have the immersive
i'm a big sound person someone's voice i
like to imagine
i love the idea of dipsy because i can
just lay back and just rely on my ears
for pleasure can you imagine if you made
a dipsy and sent it to esther
i actually think that's a great gift for
her i do think it is yeah that little
horn ball that sticky-fingered little
boy for listeners of the show dipsy is
offering an extended 30-day free trial
when you go to dipsystories.com
tuesday that's 30 days of full access
for free when you go to dipsy that's
d-i-p-s-e-a
stories dot com slash tuesday dipsy
stories dot com slash tuesday oh my
favorite
athletic greens you guys annie and i
cannot get enough of this i love it this
is how i start my day i know
eight ounces the cold water my little
powder it tastes so good it's shocking
you're really like get it taste it you
will know that we're not messing with
you because i just think it's so good
and i didn't
i've been intermittent fasting and i had
to come to the show and i didn't get to
have mine and i feel
i feel not as good i don't feel
vegged up yet i i gotta here's what i'll
say although i am pretty diligent about
eating vegetables every day there just
are some days where i'm not able to i'm
on the go i'm not or i'm eating out they
don't have vegetables i like athletic
greens just eliminates all of the
thinking you're getting your vitamins
and minerals and all of your nutrients
and all of your the good stuff that you
get from vegetables first thing in a day
and you don't have to think about it
they're so good it comes with you can
order the kit where it comes with the
own shaker bottle so you can just shake
it right up it's just so easy
it's so good i'm so happy that we're
sponsored by them and we get to just
brag about it because it's really my
favorite so with athletic greens you're
absorbing 75 high quality vitamins
minerals whole food source superfoods
probiotics and adaptogens to help you
start your day right and what i love
about athletic greens it's it's keto
paleo vegan dairy free or gluten free it
also costs less than three dollars a day
you're investing in your health and it's
cheaper than a cold brew and by the way
if you don't take our word for it a lot
of professional athletes swear by
athletic grains my personal trainer who
trains by the way she's been out of town
for four weeks i don't know if you can
notice but
she's on a movie but she trains like the
marvel stars freaked out when she walked
into my house and saw the athletic
greens and i was like not only do i have
these in my house but i'm sponsored by
them so i'm telling you it's it's giving
me street grid right now it's time to
reclaim your health and arm your immune
system with convenient daily nutrition
especially heading into the flu in cold
season it's just one scoop and a cup of
water every day that's it that's it no
need for a million different pills and
supplements to look out for your health
i'm just so happy to not have when i
take vitamins i'm burping up you know
when it doesn't get fully down and you
have that vitamin burp all day
this this is the way this is the future
we're in it right now to make it easy
athletic greens is going to give a free
one-year supply of immune supporting
vitamin d and five free travel packs to
your first purchase all you have to do
is visit athleticgreens.com
tuesday again that's athleticgreens.com
tuesday to take ownership over your
health and pick up the ultimate daily
nutritional insurance
uh yeah every once in a while i have to
talk to my ex when i'm handing him my
keys to park my car
i go don't forget you were ever in this
car
dating comics was the worst career
decision you've made i think
but i came out of it alive you did come
out of it alive but you about to get one
of these texts
is that a conscious choice like you have
to make like up front like i was a guy
i'm not gonna date a comic all right i
am open to dating a comic
i always said i'm only gonna date indian
girls so there were no indian females i
was attracted to yeah
and i don't think she felt any i think
it's a very like
i'm not dating indians yeah yeah yeah
we have a real brother sister thing but
that's for the most part like nah it
wasn't an issue for me why was it really
important for you to want to um um
marion because i grew up around white
people and i it like i'm home i'm indian
but then everywhere else it's hard to be
proud to be an indian
and i know the world has changed so much
since i was a kid so this doesn't really
necessarily apply anymore but like when
i found my roots and found pride in who
i was my whole life really turned around
not that i was some i wouldn't be like a
[ __ ] drug addict or whatever but like
i don't think i'm successful without
finding my roots and pride in who i am
and then i was like yo
the only chance i have uh the only
reason i was able to do this is because
i had two indian parents i couldn't run
for my identity and then when i embraced
it i was like oh i'm from a beautiful
place with a beautiful culture beautiful
faith everything so i wanted to marry
somebody who shared those roots life is
a different religion than me but that
was something i was always i wasn't that
pressed for i could marry a muslim girl
or a sick girl or whatever christian
girl even fine but then i wanted them to
be from where i'm from so our kids would
have that and we could pass that culture
that was like a decision to me and your
parents were probably happy did they see
you kind of like deviating and then
coming back they probably were like so
related i'm sure they're happy but they
didn't press that a ton either my mom
just wanted me to be with somebody smart
and pretty yeah that's it that's all she
wanted i don't care what race smart
pretty i love that if you brought some
i'll go home she was not gonna have it
she'd much rather me be with like a
beautiful black doctor than like some
ugly dumb indian you know what i mean
she don't care my mom was not
necessarily she didn't go for pretty but
she really cared about height because
she's one of the few tall filipinos and
my dad was 6'4 my sister's six feet tall
so imagine
imagine
bringing
the first time she met bobby was at a
place called jin sushi in pasadena
imagine my mom's having a little serve
in us yes having to look down at my
lover like physically look down
and he was like you know he's portly and
he's just so cute he kind of looks like
a piece of sushi
funny like the roundness of like a piece
of fish laying over rice yeah you think
bobby owes a thank you to your mom
because if you weren't trying to spite
her on some level yeah i mean you
probably wouldn't have looked at this
guy twice the first time i feel like
that's such an asian thing like there's
always like a physical
thing your parents want whether it's
pretty whether it's tall don't [ __ ] up
our tall jeans yeah just some weird
thing that they you know they hold well
for indians it was arranged marriages
like my parents they had a crazy
arranged marriage my dad didn't even
know he was getting married till the day
he got married he found out at another
family member's wedding you're getting
married i think i mean you gotta go
bring that back bring that energy back
it works out about the same rate as the
love marriages i've seen about half the
indian arranged marriages i see they're
happy and about half of them they hate
each other can they get divorced or that
now yeah but
back then no yeah
but uh for them it was just historically
so compatibility based and that's the
idea like let's just get two people who
are compatible i think that's the idea
let's get two people who are compatible
let's make it work but compatible in
what way just on the bio data yeah
exactly
yeah yeah yeah and then matchmaker
favorite show my sister-in-law was on
that show my wife was on that show for a
second rupam with the crazy father yes
that's my father-in-law oh my god yes
the one that you're watching you're like
whoa this guy's this guy's this guy's
intense we gotta blow that episode up
you guys season what is it on netflix
season one episode eight yeah the show
was like a phenomenon it's such a great
show
is the one that has the daughter you see
her along here right now i see her which
i was a great choice on my sister's
behalf but yeah she was on that show my
whole in-laws are on that show amazing
yeah yeah i love that shirt i mentioned
netflix before i did you know
demoralizing that was
you're killing me doug
yeah yeah but it's like that's such an
old-school way it's like you gather
someone's you know bio data and you
hopefully you know figure but there's so
many elements you just can't account for
no you can't but to them it's like i
think they're coming from a place where
like look we just need to almost like
evolutionary [ __ ] like we're not here
really thriving a ton in this country we
might be thriving but like the general
perception is we just need to survive
and pass on the genes so everything we
do is about these kids so compatibility
genes having tall kids let's great let's
do that i think that's how they look at
it i give them the benefit of the doubt
there where it's like hey you guys are
going to be happy if your kids are happy
and healthy and successful so y'all
figure that [ __ ] out whatever it is just
give them the strongest genes possible
is it usually people that they know or
is it complete strangers or is it like
someone from town or they're like oh my
dad used to get married people from my
dad's village get married from people
from my mom's village so they kind of
already did yeah yeah there was a
connection but i feel like there's so
many like must have been so many times
where someone had a crush and they were
like yeah gunning for that person and
their parents were like no you gotta go
with her like i would scheme to make
sure that i was matched with that person
eventually yeah i would like plant seeds
i think if the cast and [ __ ] lined up
that happened
but the cast had to line up i remember
one of my cousins in india saying our
parents don't care about any of this
stuff we just got to marry somebody from
the same cast and i was like bro you've
done narrowed the [ __ ] out
i don't know if you know that or not but
yeah you eliminated 99 of the world so
there are cousins but that's um that's
sort of why i sort of grieve a little
bit the filipino mentality because we
always want to marry out like we were so
much self-loathing and so much like you
know we're very we were colonized for
over 300 years or it's like we live in
that colonized mind so much it's so hard
to crawl out of so the mixed babies are
who are revered the mestizos like they
used to call it like lymphyasa de sangre
like the cleaning of the blood so if we
had them mixed
with the filipino then somehow they
would be better everything in our media
is like skin whitening all the actors
are not dark skinned actors and it's
sort of like this thing that that
constant like i was looked at as
better yeah you know growing up i was
like oh look at those pretty girls look
can i tell you another thing this is
something i thought about as i thought i
want to be successful and invariably you
will get looked at as a role model i
noticed when i was watching tv american
tv american film i never saw a happy
indian couple ever it was always an
indian is supposed to get an arranged
marriage and then falls in love with a
non-indian and then they choose the
non-indian as they should in that case
but like or an indian guy that wants to
[ __ ] everything on earth never an indian
girl but he can't because he's too weird
or whatever or like uh something or an
indian guy who keeps singing the beatles
yes
for sure and then i'm sure falls in the
white girl in that movie you don't see
happy indian couples and i would see all
these like super militant guys that were
like for their people never marry
someone of their people so it was again
and i really do think you know my wife
and i god made us for each other i
believe that but like before that i was
like i'm going to marry an indian
because i'm not going to perpetuate that
[ __ ] yeah i'm not going to do that and
then again luckily i met this girl that
i'm super in love with and she's very in
love with me so it worked but
that was a thing that was like i was
conscious about that so you're saying i
break up with bobby and find well you
can't break up with bobby you gotta have
to have a half okay i'm gonna have to
bang brendan wardell sorry oh my god yes
and it'd still be fifty percent filipino
yeah he's half filipino am i
perpetuating the other side of what
you're saying because i am going out and
telling white girls to date asian men
i'm spreading the word i'm saying what
have i been doing
you're doing you're doing good because i
think that you know historically asian
men have been de-sexualized i just can't
believe it
we were wrong we were everyone's been
wrong it was the dick game is great
dude and also it's like japanese porn i
don't know if i've always watched asian
porn and i've always thought asian men
were hot because obviously i grew up in
asia so coming to america and now we're
back to [ __ ] look at how it always
comes full circle
there you go
is that amazing yes
that's impressive good call
so coming here and like you know
no one ever had crushes on the asian
boys yeah and i'm like you guys are
really behind yeah really bad now it's
not like that obviously the world's
changed everyone's in love with a
[ __ ] character on a k drama but yeah
but i i did have a crush on two asians
throughout my life but you're right it
was like we i would go like wow i have a
crush on it like i
thought it through yeah it was a thing
where it was like wait a white girl with
an asian guy like back then growing up
that's just like i had a friend in
college good looking kid he kind of was
into this white girl and then i heard
she told her friends like yeah but i
don't know if i could date an asian guy
and she had like they had a vibe but she
just wouldn't do it that sucks yeah i
think kids today are so [ __ ]
different that even these things i think
are so important they're like dude we
don't give a [ __ ] about any of that yeah
we're out here we're not even a gender
anymore if i was like if i adopted what
you're saying where i was like listen i
just want to keep my culture
specifically what it is
the only like quaker 25 percent jewish
is my twin brother i would have to marry
and bang my twin brother i got no
problem with white people who were like
i like being white but the thing that
you don't have to fight with is i'm
losing my right identity right that's
why to me it was a thing but again now
nobody cares so these kids are probably
i'm probably antiquated in my way of
thinking also i don't know bobby but i
love bobby he can't bring him a bobby
that's yeah you won yeah he won he won't
let it happen he's gonna chain me down
with this fake katana
my boyfriend's mom is laotian and she's
so like i mean she was like in
you know camps and stuff as a kid and
like she just had such a crazy
upbringing and they had to like escape
and
her dad or her dad was like a spy and so
they got sponsored over here so she's
been through all this stuff and she she
doesn't like care about other stuff but
she'll like she cook she loves like
to cook and you know feed everyone and
stuff like that and she'll i'll go i
love that soup and she's like oh i'll
come teach you how to make it and i'm
like i don't know if you
understand if anything's getting cooked
in my house it is by your son i am never
going to be
like whatever
thing cultural thing it will stop here
and i'm not trying to be disrespectful
i'm just being very realistic i will be
served i'm sorry
i don't know do you make more money than
him yes i do there you go that's fine if
you're not going to make money and
you're not going to cook i'm going to be
like
no no yeah no i'm not like there's no i
do believe that the breadwinner you know
yeah
sometimes i go don't even pay the rent
this month just cook and clean
that's fine sometimes that's a good deal
that's fire that's why is that the rule
akash like i don't believe in gender
rules if the man is not making money he
is making money i'm just making it up
yeah yeah yeah i told my wife before we
got on like our second date i said as
long as this goes i want you to work as
hard as you want make as much money as
you want i fully support you in anything
you want to do i do want you to know
however much money you make i'm going to
kill myself to make more yeah so if in
the event that somehow she just creeps
above you is she allowed not to cook
that
oh and my wife don't have to cook i
don't also don't want to be that thing
i'll help however but like
if i if she was making more than me i
feel obligated like i gotta clean up i
gotta cook it's the only way i can feel
worth also i'm just competitive like i
wanna make more than my brother my dad
like i'm gonna wanna make more than you
just as a competitor i know isn't it fun
to just kind of soar above your family
yeah it's nice
it's just like you need money ask me oh
my parents are like yeah we got it the
toilet exploded or whatever i go how
much
that's the best dude it is come talk to
me i do not i have not
from these people coming from here she
literally is like under when i don't
know where kalaila is i assume she's
well under i don't know
what the ocean from filipinos though
there's some people there right we have
the bajau and
they're actually
where they actually have enlarged spleen
so they can stay underwater for 15
minutes wow
so they will find me annie i love that
15 minutes 15 [ __ ] minutes i think
that they have like some form of like
like modified gills or something so i
cannot hide under water too long my
family will find i have to pay you a
compliment i the shoes and the shirt
being kind of like this
off the hairy legs really good
oh let me tell you about these shoes
these are not mine these are bobby's
okay how much do you think he paid for
these shoes five hundred dollars correct
really
i know bobby i feel bobby i live there's
this thing where you can buy
pre-distressed um chucks and i don't
know how they do it but it's from italy
some guy just wears it out for a couple
of years and then yeah
yeah so that's what bobby is into and
i've heard of you wearing them and
selling them for a lot of money but i
haven't heard about a guy and what a
racket right this is wait the feet picks
or the distressed the distribution picks
i get i've never bought them but i i
like a good foot so i guess
my wife got descending toe length and i
noticed that when we first met and if it
wasn't for that i don't know if i had
the hard to ask for her number but when
i saw that in an indian girl i was like
i have to like you like when the toe
goes a little bit the descending order
no longer that's me
is is a um deal breaker so
thank you you said it you know what i
mean thank god any do we have descending
total length what is it
my wikifeet rating is pretty good my toe
descends but it's not mine's mine are
fine
my wikifeed is did you say bookie feet
yes you can uh you can get a thousand
dollars or under on my whether my toes
are ascending or not
yeah okay that's good to know now i'm
going to chop off my
second toe
these people know they're the experts
yes and here's i'm just a guy with one
preference you know some people yes it's
all different because i'm always like i
always ask audience members i'm like are
you like this guy or like trying to get
[ __ ] through the toes because a lot of
you know what i mean
like so then they're looking more at
arches and souls
but if you're if you're between the toe
you're probably looking for like a
a larger guy michael blaustein is like
bigger than a feet than me that guy's
really yeah should we have him on i have
so many questions yeah yeah 100 percent
he'll answer all your questions he's got
a whole podcast that's basically just
fit foot talk at the end of the day
yeah stiff socks you know what i mean
it's in that title
[Laughter]
wow and so i what i my knowledge of foot
fetishes are that it's like the foot
part and the genital part of your brain
are really close and sometimes they kind
of just like that makes sense that adds
up so like you just get like a sec
that guy i mean look i got friends
andrew's really in the feet notice his
arches all that stuff me i noticed the
toes i'm a toe guy okay you know what i
mean but blau he's [ __ ] broke what
about beat porn and everything i have a
question if you guys do it it's not like
objectifying it's like it's almost like
you're like giving like you know the way
it does positive you know you know the
way the judge looks at a westminster
that's me dog
feet like i'm objectively like that's a
good foot that's a bad foot that can't
get a trophy i have a question for you
so let's say
let's suppose it's
perfect dimensions
um descending toes yeah i'm listening
okay
are you looking at it for potential or
for what it is for instance if you have
all of the right measurements but she
current she just ran a marathon and she
has a couple corns and a couple blisters
on there are you looking at what it
could be or what it is
i think i'm probably what it is
yeah probably what it is because you
don't want to think past like a surgery
yeah no it's not a surgery she's just i
don't know about a marathon but
nails toenails 26 miles guys
now we know she's talking about bobby's
feet
i finally got that [ __ ] to get a
pedicure i want to get tired and he got
bright orange as a color oh that's funny
that's a bobby caution yeah again i
don't know i've never met bobby before i
know about him i said bobby move he's
like caution under construction yeah
exactly but i he i heard from brandon
wardell that guys who paint their
fingernails and toenails are
queerbaiting
really but now it's in this like in the
zeitgeist ii queerbait it's like
queerbaiting is like now what
is like that's trying to get dudes to
[ __ ] you is queerbaiting well you know
like that's probably what you use that
term in a very different way when i was
pretending you're gay to get a girl kind
of like yeah remember that full
yeah i didn't know you pretended to be
gay i think that's what it means no it's
a different one matthew perry i know
which one you're talking about i had
never campbell i know my rom-coms dude
wait i want to ask you about rom-coms
love them okay are there
rom-coms that you think are specifically
geared for men like what are some male
rom-coms because i was trying to
knock knocked up as a comedy you think
it's most it's common
what about hitch
hitch is probably for dudes that was
free my wife loves it i love it but
hitch is probably that's actually okay
hitch has played a really big role in my
relationship because todd always says he
does 90 and i do 10. and that's from the
kiss but that's just like how we operate
our lives yeah i watched it the other
day and while certain things are a
little bit like cringe now i think it's
still it's still okay
what's cringe about it
certain just certain things that he says
like along the way were just like all
right that doesn't quite like hold up as
you know as the years have passed but
what are other male rom-coms like i
i cannot watch a single rom-com with
bobby
well hold on adam sandler movies are
those rom-coms oh yeah wedding singer
he's probably a male romance you're
getting sir marshall
i love you man it's a bromance movie
specifically that's a fire movie
okay that's my whole life is i love it
who are just friends that one's just
number one is actually the number one
one of the best movies i've ever seen in
my life just just when harry met sally
but not as good
we did have laughs it's rewatch it have
you watched it recently uh i watched it
over christmas
i just watched we just it's it's i
laughed the entire time i couldn't
believe it everyone plays such a
character i'm also a justin timberlake
hater just i just
he's not oh no this one that one is bad
friends of benefits that's a bad one
just friends is with uh amy smart and
um ryan reynolds okay i've heard of this
i've heard this is very funny chris
klein is that his name no i heard this
is super fun um anna ferris is hilarious
and it's so funny okay no i've heard
this is funny i actually need to rework
i need to watch this but
chris klein is
so funny yeah he was great i mean that
was so good i mean
i would say that i've really very rarely
seen ryan reynolds not be
guy's fantastic i mean unbelievable he's
hot he's funny what don't he have he's
so [ __ ] hilarious ah gosh um we do on
the show um midway through or when we're
having feelings so we take a banana
break
love bananas me too i overlooked them
for years
you gotta
[Laughter]
that's wild i've never seen a banana
look like that i've never seen a banana
look like this in my life
i'm eating around there this is like
that's bobby's penis tip
looks just like that
why does it have a carcinogen on it
that's bad he has like neapolitan ice
cream colored dick he really has it's
tri-colored really depending on how the
light hits it couldn't be four colors
todd's is all jack because he had like a
thing when he was circum he told me this
like first date i guess he just likes to
let you know his penis is going to have
a thing
yeah you got it you open with it but he
um it was like when he got circumcised
there was like they didn't fully
circumcise it so then when he was like
14 he had to go in because his dick was
like attached still the hedgehog holy
crap that hurts when you get a big boner
he would have had to like like he must
have had to like get like a q-tip to
clean in between that little he pretty
much had a prince albert
yeah you got to put a ring through so i
come from a culture where if you're not
circumcised you are um humility like
your t is your whole upbringing right
and so what does that mean
uncircumcised but it's like you're
lesser of a human it's really mean it's
not true guys um
because i am fine with the uncut cut
don't care um
but my the guy that i dated for a while
my possibly brother i'm a brother [ __ ]
akash
we don't know if he's really my brother
but i [ __ ] him anyways but
um he didn't get circumcised
yeah it's always worth it we do look
alike it's scary i don't see if he's hot
though is it worth it yeah you know it
was
yeah all right
you had bigger shoulders
[Laughter]
but this guy when he would get boners he
would be in a lot of pain because his
skin couldn't you know they could cut
off too much ah so the was real tight
yeah and i felt so bad for him so i
would
get him horny but not too horny so it's
like a fine line yeah i i want to
apologize to my brothers
i'm sorry i thought i was a good sister
i did nothing for you
i never touched your dicks at all
having hot sisters rough dude
you gotta worry about everybody else
[ __ ] this girl you can't that's not
that's not fair
yeah
what in existence do you know who assa
akira is the porn star the name i've
heard oh this is a good boy good
marriage she is um she is a goddess a
brilliant woman she always says like
without a doubt like if i had a brother
and he was good looking absolutely i
would have [ __ ] them she has uh
she dreams about
not being an only child oh
so she could [ __ ] her brother yeah maybe
she had a maybe she had a twin and she
[ __ ] him into her body
and now she's just an extra appendage
yeah
i used to do a joke saying that i my
twin brother and i were born siamese his
that my head was right by his death
[Laughter]
you have a twin brother for real
that's my dream as a twin boy and girl
well you know you can do it with ivf
i know so weird
you have to pay for your dream babies
okay i feel like somebody some like you
might be i don't know you're playing yes
no i think the lord will punish them yes
i feel like god will punish you yeah
yeah
like it's taking some things in your own
head but then i think about it on the
other end if this technology was created
it was created under
the rule of god's watch or whatever so
it's like whether you're religious or
whatever you're looking at it as it is
like
are we being idiots for not taking the
technology that has naturally mm-hmm
yeah that's a good thought i i want twin
boy and girl but again i do fear it like
i don't know
something she's so lucky to get a kid
they would they will be thank you akash
thank you guys so much you've been
wonderful thank you um we hope you come
back and we hope you have a special
coming out i have a specialist out on
youtube called bring back a poo check it
out
one million views in one week so hell
yeah and as quickly as we can and that
is uh is that a direct attack at hari
kondabalu no it's a direct attack that
the mentality that like we're victims
yeah i don't like that [ __ ] no we're not
that's awesome we're here we're
privileged let's be great and will you
do my show at red star bar in greenville
yes in 2000
what year was uh 16 14 whatever it was
2012 probably who knows
all right thank you guys so much for
watching check out akash and all the
stuff he's doing and thank you so much
thank you guys appreciate subscribe like
we're trying to get to 200 000
subscribers this week
see you guys
[Music]
you